the Joe Rogan experience that's why I
wanted to steal the the humanity and the
for the money and all that take over all
the humanity we got to be careful of
anything that separates people we didn't
a necessary thing that doesn't really
mean you know what and you know what I
do for real and the people always ask me
about the trip I don't know why that's
one of the reasons why I don't use
colored emojis all my emojis I use be
yellow for the most part unless it's a
joke I'm trying to do because I feel
like that's still pushing the separation
mmm you know saying so it's like to me I
don't feel like this like it's no reason
that the yellow is in any like why are
you ain't using this I'm using yellow
ain't using white or black I'm using
yellow right nothing yellow fake people
and it's yellow big fake just given this
it's still given the same exact thing is
just yellow
yes it's just laughter yes laughter
smiley face crying laughs yeah I'd only
have to be a black laughter unless I'm
telling the joke of something memes like
like black man don't cheat that's right
I need the black fish right I don't give
a [ __ ] Jamie had a good point once about
emojis that they're like the new higher
go fix yeah what available language
eventually becomes a series of emojis
that's all of this we ain't gotta talk
no more totally possible we don't really
have to talk it like we own our phones
if we could text and all that stuff
there you can send feelings you got push
like little things and they give a
feeling we don't have to use none of
that [ __ ] we barely use Ninian now we
better use our arms all this [ __ ] the
only thing gonna be like this pretty
soon it would be hard to convey like hey
did you go to the movie at 7 o'clock or
eight it would be hard to convey things
like that through just emojis its
o'clock yes you can you can do a change
though but then you'd say you'd have to
go movie and then the @ sign and then 7
o'clock and then you would go question
mark
eight o'clock question mark I guess you
could right there just a movie seven
eight question
yeah but seven eight is weird seven
question mark eight question mark me uh
it's two possibilities seven eight like
that
said someone he wouldn't say seven eight
what the [ __ ] are you saying he's 78
what are you saying - I'm saying I know
what you're saying but like it would be
a clock it'll be a number like this if
they came up with a language that was
all emojis that kids just learned really
early it's like that ma'am my daughter
when she talks to me it's mostly in
emojis but even when we put that
FaceTime face she like to put that on
like they do that in there like that
game what's that game she'd be playing
roblox yes that's all a road block so
that's oh they don't even talk to each
other they'd be I don't know what they'd
be doing in there but ain't no voices
they're learning how to connect with
machines they learn how to connect
through energy and feelings in in
whatever you draw or whatever your
creativity it's like we're we're
evolving out of our human body slowly
but surely I couldn't agree more
it's happening whether people recognize
it or not and it's gonna be real weird
when it takes hold and I don't know what
form it's gonna be it's gonna be a
wearable device I think my god I'm
willing to go with it I didn't think we
would be right where we at man so [ __ ]
I'm cool with it you just got to go with
it that's how you enjoy like you know
and if you ain't laughing at life you've
missing the whole point of this [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] [ __ ] fun like this [ __ ]
funny as hell just watching how stupid
this [ __ ] evolve it just it is fun it's
weird - weird time it's it's a great
time it's not great time so right now
this is it's a spoof like it's like
everything that was in living color what
we grew there or everything a comedian
said 20 years ago that we didn't see it
it's like really life now's like this
[ __ ] is really crazy yeah so it's like
just laugh at this [ __ ]
[ __ ] funny stuff but it's very strange
yeah it ain't strange it's funny it's
funny - strange is funny but I like it
[Applause]